it's really important in your life and
your career no matter which field you
pursue is that you find the right
mentors
and i've seen this a lot i think because
of how we structured academia a lot of
young people a lot of early career
researchers they think a mentor is just
a teacher
or an advisor like an academic advisor
and that's really not the case a good
mentor is far more than that a good
mentor is someone who knows when to be
your friend and when to be your boss
it's someone who knows how to teach you
but how to help you to learn how to
teach yourself
a good mentor is someone in your life
who is really going to be there for you
to help you answer questions
to steer you in the right direction when
you feel like you don't know which way
to go but also to to allow you to grow
in your own ways and so a mentor is
someone whose hindsight can become your
foresight for those of us out here in
the world who've been very fortunate and
blessed and honored to be mentors for
young students and